bem o que inicialmente era uma
prescrição médica hoje um sentido de
vida quando tinha três anos de idade
minha mãe me levou no velho no médico
pra tentar corrigir um problema nos pés
que eu tinha esse problema e não pecava
no pé ea rotação era pra dentro
o que inibe a minha estabilidade e minha
forma de caminhar como solução o médico
me indicou usa as botas ortopédicas e a
fazer balé
segundo ele os exercícios físicos do
balé clássico iria contribuir para que
eu pudesse corrigir aquele probleminha
que eu tinha nos país e assim com três
anos de idade eu comecei a fazer balé a
coisa aí começou a ficar sério mas não
mais pelo problema ortopédico que já
havia sido corrigido e que inclusive eu
adquirir tanto acaba no pé que passei
até um dos pés mais sonhados por toda
bailarina porque quanto mais cava no pé
você tem mais beleza e mais habilidades
você tem pra poder dançar e assim eu
corrigir e tive o pé tão sonhado quanto
a bailarina mas até então não tinha que
tá a seriedade que começou a ficar sério
bem a seriedade estava de como eu me
dedicava aquela dança que inicialmente
começou a preocupar a minha mãe que
vivia me perguntando você tem certeza
que quer fazer balé não quer fazer uma
outra atividade dá um tempo fazer
educação física na escola e lógico que a
resposta era sempre a mesma não eu
queria continuar
eu queria insistir naquela dança ea
preocupação de minha mãe estava no custo
disso aí quer um caro fazer balé
ela não estava nem um pouco preocupada
se eu ia levar a dança
como a profissão porque ela era muito
tranquila meus pais eram muito
tranqüilos daquela coisa do que você vai
ser quando crescer
eles queriam que eu fosse feliz que eu
fizesse uma coisa que eu me sentisse bem
então isso não era um problema mas o
custo disso que era muito alto e meus
pais se esforçaram muito para poder
pagar é que era o grande problema mas
como viu que não tinha muito jeito eles
não mediram esforços e continuarão a
pagar as minhas aulas e aí eu comecei a
investir
eu comecei a estudar comecei a respirar
ea viver aquela dança de uma forma muito
intensa e passei a medo cá pra fazer
balé clássico
você tem que ser altamente disciplinado
e foi aí que eu me vê envolvida de fato
naquela dança
eu passava horas na sala de aula todos
os dias da semana muitas aulas por dia a
chegar ao ponto de não ter final de
semana de não ter sábado domingo feriado
passeio com os amigos nem viagem com a
família tudo se tornou secundário a
partir do momento que eu estava ali o
tempo todo
vivendo aquela dança a lei
eu passei a me educaã até a disciplina
até pontualidade a ter comprometimento
de entender que para você ter um êxito
você precisa se esforçar e esse esforço
chegava muitas vezes há um cansaço tão
extremo e exaustivo de nome da conta se
eu ia conseguir estar ali
eu me lembro como hoje em um certo dia
em que eu fazendo uma aula porque ia
fazer uma avaliação e essa aula era uma
aula de saltos acredite não querer ver
uma aula de salt ela é tão cansativa que
só nós bailar e mas conseguimos resistir
pelo amor que nós temos por ela e ali
insistentemente persistindo
repetitivamente aquele movimento
eu me dei conta que eu estava tão
cansado e exaustiva que eu ajoelhei
naquele momento eu ajoelhei no chão e
comecei a chorar com uma aula particular
minha professora lhe parado na frente
eu chorei por alguns minutos até me
acalmar
joguei as lágrimas levantem novamente e
me posicionei e ela lei só esperando a
partir do momento que eu me posicionei
ela começou a retirar ela começou a
fazer a contagem do tempo para que eu
voltasse a repetir aquele exercício e
assim eu fiz com o olho cheio de
lágrimas repetir e repetir até chegar à
talvez o que estava próximo daquele
movimento que parecia ser o adequado
ali eu comecei a me dedicar e a fazer
todos os exames avaliativos para se
adquirir a formação de uma bailarina
clássica numa das mais conceituadas
instituições de dança de formação de
professores e bailarinos clássicos do
mundo que a royal academy of dance de
londres e assim meus queridos com 14
anos eu estava formada a nível
internacional bem e os anos foram
passando mas ali tão jovem ainda eu
comecei a perceber o quanto era
importante aquela dança na minha vida
oculta ela me transformava não só como
bailarina o quanto ela me transformava
como pessoa eu comecei a perceber o
quanto eu era responsável
o quanto eu era dedicada o quanto estava
forte e pronta para superar os desafios
que a dança tinha ensinado isso eu
estava ali preparada para receber ou não
eu estava ali preparada para errar
isso fazia parte da minha vida de uma
forma muito comum porque eu sabia que
podia superá los
eu sabia que eu podia inclusive revertê
los porque a dança me deu essa força de
persistir
xixi e talvez alcançar isso não tivesse
alcançado persiste mais um pouquinho
e assim foram os anos passando e eu ali
assistindo para assisti-lo persistindo
passaram-se o tempo eu cheguei num
determinado tempo e passei a ser mãe
quando eu passei a ser mãe eu comecei a
entender o sentido da vida quando eu
entendi o sentido da vida comecei a
perceber o quanto a pessoa pedir de mim
o quanto aquela o culto era eu tinha que
ser um exemplo o quanto eu tinha que ser
lhe orientar e educar aquela criança que
era meus filhos e aí eu comecei a me dar
conta até que ponto aquela dança tão
técnica tão formal tão bem estruturada
tinha para poder acertar com relação aos
meus filhos além da responsabilidade da
dedicação e foi quando eu percebi que
estava faltando alguma coisa
faltava algo talvez com relação à
sensibilidade com relação à essência
faltava aldo talvez nem eu mesmo sabia
identificar e pela primeira vez na minha
vida eu decidi parar a decidir para a
dança porque eu estava vindo tanto
sentido de sensibilidade com relação à
minha pessoa e assim eu fiz pela
primeira vez eu decidi parar a mv dentro
de um escritório administrativo
trabalhando e isso durou pouco mais de
um ano e meio tempo suficiente para mim
perceber o quanto que a dança fazia
falta na minha vida
um belo dia eu conversando com meu chefe
que conhecia minha história de vida
minha história com a dança ela disse
tana você tem certeza você que sempre
foi tão talentosa tão dedicada tão
apaixonada pela dança que você não volta
volta a dançar não volta a ensinar e
naquele tempo naquela conversa que eu
tive com ela não pensando muito de um
dia pro outro e resolvi que ia mudar
aliás eu não eu meu marido e meus filhos
eu e meu marido naquele momento de fato
de um dia
outro pediu demissão pedimos demissão
reunimos poucas coisas que tínhamos e
resolvemos mudar de vida e de cidade
na época eu morava em que a bola e
decidir a cidade de vitória da conquista
para recomeçar
reunimos poucas coisas que tínhamos
resolvemos com relação à moradia à
escola
colocamos tudo no caminhão de mudança e
pegamos a estrada e aqui chegamos
chegando aqui no mesmo lugar que eu
decidir morar
era minha escola lá nessa escola eu era
professora recepcionista porteira tudo o
que fosse necessário e eu não me
importava nem um pouco isso porque eu me
propus aquilo eu não queria recomeçar
que fosse do zero então eu passei fazer
um pouquinho de cada coisa sem nenhum
problema
foi aí que eu me ver nos maiores
desafios da minha vida que era me
reeducar a reinventar a minha dança com
relação a ser professor mas um professor
que tinha uma ideologia um pensamento
uma essência associada toda aquela
técnica que eu tinha aprendido durante
anos eu precisava reinventar pra mostrar
e ensinar uma dança para corpos que
muitas vezes não tinham tantas
habilidades
eu tive que me reinventar porque eu
passei a ter um público que me procurava
não pela profissão que a dança oferecia
mas como refúgio como tratamento
emocional como uma forma de se
reconhecer e de chegar mais próximas do
que elas são e aí eu me vi nesse desafio
pra vocês terem uma noção a minha
primeira luna se matricular na escola
ela tinha transtorno no espectro autista
o que eu me vi numa situação nova e
desafiadora desafiadora
não só pelas necessidades especiais que
ela tinha
mas se realizar o sonho dela de ser
bailarina com seis meses
tava fazendo aula comigo ela estava
dançando no meu primeiro espetáculo
junto com todos os outros e por igual e
aí eu me vi naquela naquela situação e
disse
ela não sabe mas eu aprendi muito mais
com ela do que ela comigo e assim com
esse encontro que eu tive com ela novas
habilidades dessa etapa o leão começaram
a surgir porque cada vez mais eu me via
em novos desafios e novas personalidades
em novos corpos e novas expectativas mas
acredita em nenhum mais difícil do que
superar a frieza das pessoas
a dureza de perceber que as pessoas
queriam apenas a aparência não bastava
você tem um trabalho de qualidade nem
ter boas intenções
bastava a aparência do lugar que se
ensina e da pessoa que se ensina e
aquilo pra mim era angustiante porque eu
estava em uma situação que eu buscava
muito mais do que aquilo mas lidar
diretamente com essa frieza foi sem
dúvidas o maior desafio da minha vida e
por seu maior desafio da minha vida eu
tive as minhas maiores inspirações
foi quando eu criei o espetáculo a
cegueira da alma
o espetáculo seguirá da alma ele é um
enredo que é todo baseado na capacidade
da pessoa de enxergar além das
aparências e acreditem com grupo de
bailarinos amigos cheios de boas
intenções nada diferentes
nada de profissionais mas eles estavam
ali para mostrar aquela dança e para
minha surpresa em todos os lugares no
qual nós dançamos em palcos competitivos
nós fomos premiados e ali daquele
sentimento que eu tinha que eu estava
naquele momento que me trouxe aquela
inspiração
eu me me vi ganhando forças
além de ganhar forças e eu comecei a
perceber que aquela era a dança que
encantava que aquela dança que cantava
era dança que eu acreditava e aí meus
queridos eu comecei a luta a luta por
estudo estudar buscar aperfeiçoar
recentemente acabei de graduar na uma
das mais importantes profissões de
técnicas de balé clássico que também da
royal academy of dance que me dá o
registro de professor de balé clássico a
nível internacional ano que vem estará
indo para a inglaterra para a minha
formatura
comecei a estudar comecei a estudar
comecei a participar dos maiores
festivais de dança do país
comecei a ler a pesquisar e hoje eu
tenho um corpo de baile
esse corpo de baile é um grupo de
bailarinas que representa a escola nos
mais diversos festivais do país eles
meus queridos tem as mais diferentes
características físicas que um bailarino
possa ter
mas eles têm uma coisa que é uma
propriedade artística
eles têm uma capacidade de se tornarem
únicos no palco e essa capacidade que
eles têm quando eles se unem se torna
uma unidade mas com essa capacidade de
se tornar no único todo esforço é
exigido o rigor que eu aprendi lá na
minha infância o rigor que eu aprendi de
técnica de persuasão de pontualidade de
esforço eu reproduzo isso com os meus
bailarinos eles muitas vezes não têm os
finais de semana passam horas chegam
pela manhã e sair pela noite
muitas vezes não têm um passeio no
shopping muitas vezes ele chora em sala
de aula mas eles enxugou as lágrimas e
volta a praticar porque eles acreditam
que podem superar e são felizes assim
recentemente voltamos da argentina onde
levamos 11 coreografias
e trouxemos 17 prêmios dentre eles do
dois prémios de excelência e significa
que você tenha nota máxima de todos os
jurados
eu fui premiado a nível internacional
como melhor preparadora e eles foram
indicados para dois festivais
internacionais
o da itália e do méxico e por isso
queridos com todo esforço com toda
dedicação eu concluo aqui pra vocês
quando vocês acreditam em alguma coisa
mesmo que ela vai de encontro a maioria
das pessoas
insista persista lute por aquilo que
você acredita porque um dia você aposta
porque eu fiz eu faço e continuarei a
fazer ea acreditar de que a dança é
muito mais do que físico
a dança ela transforma e forma
indivíduos
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]